la question de la gérance chinoise est à
nouveau imposée au Parlement mais cette
fois sous une forme différente ça fait
bien des mois qu'on est conscient de
pose de police chinoise à travers le
pays et on est en train de s'assurer que
la GRC est en train de faire des suivis
là-dessus les présumés
une enquête publique indépendante on est
rendu à deux postes de police chinois au
Québec plus de 10 circonscriptions ou la
Chine serait intervenue pour influencer
l'élection des rapports des services de
renseignement
ignorer qui va se lever dans ce
gouvernement pour parler au Premier
ministre lui faire entendre raison pour
le chef conservateur c'est un argument
de plus pour que le gouvernement mette
rapidement en place au registre des
agents d'influence étrangers il est au
courant de ces ménages depuis des années
il a eu beaucoup de temps pour consulter
déjà donc quand le dates s'il vous plaît
juste un trou d'eau n'a pas de date pour
l'instant le vraiment consulte sur la
question on aura peut-être pas
uneanimité et puis on ne sait toujours
pas qui sera le rapporteur spécial les
parties sont invités à faire des
suggestions mais au bout de la ligne ce
sera le gouvernement qui choisira car on
devrait juger
le choix de cette personne parle à
personne elle-même sur le plan de la
diplomatie les conservateurs insinues
que la ministre des Affaires étrangères
ne fait pas le poids
univers
la ministre confirme que Visa
diplomatique a été refusé que
l'ambassadeur a été convoquée et qu'elle
a discuté des gérances avec son
homologue chinois la semaine dernière il
faut en faire plus du Luc Bertone
face à la Chine mais les faits parlent
de même les faits parlent de même on a
pas expulsé aucun diplomate ça fait
maintenant 4 jours que le gouvernement a
déposé son plan pour rassurer les
électeurs en ce qui concerne la gérance
chinoise et on attend toujours qu'il se
concrétise tant qu'il ne prendra pas
forme juste un Trudeau aura de la
difficulté à esquiver les critiques ici
Valérie Gamache au Canada
Ottawa